New York was very innovative I like to
tell the people in the developing world
look New York I mean I New York is very
innovative it was innovate in the past I
like to tell the people in the
developing world's with this look
european parks were mostly the
playgrounds of the wealthy of the nobles
and the Kings and the aristocrats and
sometimes he took he was necessary to
cut their heads off in order to turn
this land into parks but Central Park
was a part don't buy a democracy and it
was done around eighteen seventy when
New York was a smaller and poorer than
most developing countries cities today
and even with that example developing
country cities don't have many central
like park examples to show but i would
say that recently New York has invested
again in public pedestrian space has
some dumb very interesting things the
Hudson River Park the bicycle ways what
has been done recently by janette
sadik-khan d Transport Commissioner of
mr. Bloomberg it making more bicycle
ways so far only painted lanes mostly
but hopefully more and more they will be
physically protected bicycle ways they
have created the High Line the elevated
the former rail line which has been
turned into a park a bit the same as
there is one in Paris too I'm the these
are fantastic public restaurant spaces
this new public restaurant space and
some that are taking care of by private
organizations such as Central Park but I
think
first there are some things that are
still needed for the future and some
others that have to be done to better
conserve what exists I mean the main
issue is New York sidewalks I am very
concerned when your side was there is a
lot of dirt and the vendors are really
taking over the near side was and
somehow people think this is democratic
to allow anybody to go and sell anything
in this three know the vendors are not a
poor people the poor people are the
hundreds of thousands of people who walk
in New York sidewalks and if we want a
new york to be new york public space to
be a space for integration between the
wealthy and the poor we have to keep
this clean and there is nothing wrong
about having beautiful spaces now people
just put up ATM machines in the
sidewalks and nobody seems to tell them
anything and some some streets in New
York really are almost now like if they
were in the most backward developing
world cities like Canal Street and and
but even in many places so I think New
York sidewalks need to be better kept
vendors have to be radically restrained
I mean you may allow a few vendors it's
supposedly with some restrictions and
some regulations but this really and
becoming is getting to a point where
it's completely cutting and so they say
is that there are some constitutional
restrictions to restrict vendors but I
don't see why because in Chicago
disciples are perfect and you have the
same Constitution in Chicago so I think
that is you have to be extremely careful
but the thing is that you see that the
new pedestrian spaces that have been
created or the ones that are kept by the
private sector like Central Park or the
high line or the Hudson River Park they
are beautiful they have nice flowers
they are clean they don't have vendors
why not manage in the same way your
public pedestrian space
you